thank you I noticed this afternoon that
your profile picture on Twitter has a
bulletproof vest on is that what it is
it was that for your trip to Britain was
my trip to Iraq
okay maybe we'll come back on holiday
after this yeah sorry about all this
you've written a book which is a
prophecy book it's about the future this
is high risk it seems to be because the
future tends to take us by surprise you
know Woody Allen's lying about you want
to make God laugh tell him your plans
for the future so you're sticking your
neck out so why do it we got first place
let me start by thanking you and
thanking intelligence squared of
thinking the world Geographic Society
for putting this on and thank you all
for coming we my co-author Jared and I
spent a lot of time talking about the
sort of this arguments between techno
optimism and techno pessimism and so
forth and we eventually got sort of
frustrated by the framing that
everybody's doing so we set out to sort
of explore what what the future would
look like at least of the ways that we
can predict it now and we ultimately
came out with a relatively optimistic
view with a whole bunch of very very
serious problems which is what the book
is about and it's optimistic for the
developed world you know here in the UK
it's also optimistic for the for the
developing world world for all sorts of
obvious reasons yeah I mean one of the
striking things about the book is that
sort of you get over the gadgets of the
future in the first couple of chapters
well introduction first chapter and then
it gets into the deep problems I mean
you say you're optimistic but I think
people will notice reading this book
it's not you're not particularly puffing
the company and you're saying you're not
saying the futures golden is Google the
company the company always likes to you
know
nice positive Sheen to it obvious
reasons as companies do but their think
a critical analysis says that these
tools and technology are enormous ly
valuable they're enormous ly important
and whether you like it or not the
Internet is going to happen worldwide
and all these people going to join us
and people are going to react to it
government's going to react to it
companies in react to its citizens going
to react to it citizens interact to each
other we tried to sort of lay out what
those different scenarios are and and
indeed there's a set of issues for which
at least I do not have solutions yet in
which case we sort of give general
statements that we hope maybe technology
can come along or new social etiquette
can come along when we cover those
whether it's in cyber war and privacy in
the way government's behave in robotics
and those sorts of things
Stud that point about governments I mean
one of the things you say right to the
beginning is the Internet is the largest
experiment involving anarchy in human
history now what do you mean by Anarchy
innocent well most people are most
people have a sort of relatively static
model of how people behave and they
assume that the government's are sad
that the culture is set and so forth but
that's not in fact true and we've never
had in our history a transformation with
so much power to individuals we
certainly had transitions of power to
monopolies to kings to corporations to
dictators even to central governments in
in democracies we've never had a
situation where everybody had the
equivalent of a supercomputer on there
in their hands so this is obviously
wonderful if you're a woman in a
developing world where your rights are
terrible and you're mid terribly
mistreated and you use this to document
the abuses that are occurring for women
around you and you cause shame and
outers you get that fixed but it's
equally frightening if you think about
the empowerment that these tools mean
for people who mean to do evil to others
and and you're gonna get both
okay one of the Australia striking
sentences you come out is the world
virtual population well that number the
people of Earth so we're kind of
multiplying ourselves in virtual
personalities and and one what you seem
to be saying is that this material is
going to this technology is going to
extend us in this way but also that
means invading us as well at the same
time you talk about making the online
experiment as real as life or perhaps
even better and I think you said in the
past in the future children will be
asleep or online what's to day which is
Chile children your child is online
right now or asleep there are only two
states of children now and if they wake
up in the middle in life they're gonna
be online people find that Chile I'm
just reporting the news it's what you do
every day well wouldn't you rather they
were doing something not online well I
think I think we're gonna discover that
this generation of children is far far
smarter than we were that the tools and
techniques that they are able to adapt
cause cognitive development to be
earlier their communication skills will
be better and surely their motor skills
from gaming will be far far better so
you know there's also talk of the
development of Google itself away from a
search engine I think you say suggestion
engine yeah could you elaborate on that
well let's talk a little bit about the
future for the developed world and a
simple metaphor for you which is in the
book is you wake up in the morning and
you of course you wake up with a clock
that's been time to your REM cycles who
you're woken up at exactly the right
cycle so you wake up refreshed you look
at the screen and the basic question you
want to ask is do I need to get up so
you say do I need to get up and the
screen says no how does it know with
your permission opt in all those kinds
of things it's calculated that there's
nothing that's going to make your boss
really upset today
the flights going to be late anyway you
can sleep in until you sit there you go
I don't want that yes you do you want
that extra half hour sleep trust me
and the the development of sort of
infinitely intelligent assistance is in
the path for companies like Google and
others which make your life better and
there's so many things that we can do
now with artificial intelligence machine
learning and so forth it really will
change the way you interact and
literally free up time today computers
seem to be or they sort of harass you
know this this problem and then problem
and how to respond to that computers
will get so good that they can actually
more or less anticipate what how you
should spend your time and again this is
all opt-in all because you choose
everybody gets upset about this thing
trust me there's an off button learn how
to use it right for me think of it as
instead of having a person who's your
your work assistant you have some
computer that sort of helps you out it
makes perfect sense
so if you think about from Google's
perspective the steps are there there's
a product called Google now today Google
now it's what if you don't program that
which you can it starts by trying to
figure out where you live and where you
work so you turn it on and so far it's
figured out where I live where I work
and it tells me how long it's gonna take
is that useful sure right if I
programmed it it would be able to do a
lot more I'm a bit suspicious of this
word opt-in and you say in the book
where people have a responsibility to
read a company's policies and positions
before they willing to share information
we're not gonna do that and we we all
get those screens come up which I scroll
down and turn up to thousands and
thousands of words long and we're
unlikely to decide to take on your
thousand or and our corporate lawyers in
order to get an X gadget you co to me so
we're not gonna say no I don't but I
don't think you could sue us over it
anyway I think the fact of the matter is
you're superior I think under the legal
system the first place those things are
written by lawyers who basically think
of every possible way somebody could sue
you which is why they're so long yeah so
let's start with that as a
so it might give us some idea but have
you studied the American legal system no
I just live in fear of it the the point
is that there's something in the book
which it seems to conflict with that
which is that one of the things you say
is that when security as security gets
you know develops and obviously this
week there's been the terrorist act in
London so it's it's something we're
talking about as it develops people who
are not on grid as you say maybe have a
rougher time at airports maybe they
won't be able to travel so in a way
we're being blackmailed into this system
so the opt-out is not complete well
again you're creating a possible future
scenario if you see a brand new
expensive luxury home in Pakistan that
has no connectivity whatsoever you might
think it's where Osama bin Laden is
right the fact of the matter is most
rich people in these countries are
highly connected for all sorts of
reasons they have satellite dishes and
so forth the fact of the matter is most
people are going to be connected for
whatever set of reasons and it may be
that countries will ultimately largely
ban having hidden people that the danger
of having a hidden person I'm not I'm
not arguing in favor of this I'm just
saying governments may choose to do this
because a hidden person is somebody who
the police can't figure out what they're
up to and in this new world maybe that
will ultimately be important maybe maybe
not I don't know
but I want to go back to your opt-in he
said I disagree with the framing of what
you said the at the end of the day
online services like Google depend at a
basic level on the trust of their
citizens so if we violate that trust we
will in fact lose you as a user so a
terrible thing that Google could do
would be to take the information that
we've accumulated about you and have it
by accident or because of an error you
know it was a bad employee make that
public that would not only that would
destroy Europe's you'd be very upset
with us but the whole
pounce pounce on us in a big way so
independent of the law and this privacy
statements all that which everybody
wants to argue about we have a very
strong incentive to care about your
privacy to make sure you're comfortable
with what we're doing and obviously we
make decisions which are rough judgments
so once every once while somebody
typically in Europe not in Britain
announces that we're going to have to do
opt-in for every single service and
every single page so if you think about
it what's the user the user interface of
that so every page you get you have to
opt in next page you have to opt in next
page you have to opt in so that's
generally known as blindness in the term
and what happens as you begin to be
blind to the fact you just click click
click click click and so that doesn't
strike me as a good solution to the
people who have that concern I think the
general answer is that the online world
at least in the sort of democratic world
the services are voluntary in the sense
that you do have choices officially not
monopolies in that sense and if you do
have a choice you have a choice to have
a competitor in Google's case to be
precise we make it extremely easy for
you to take your personal information
from Google and put it in a competitor's
site very part of our policies yeah I
got my personal information from Google
I thought I was 15 years older than I am
as amazing it's explained a lot about
that so I was getting
the you'd say but you do say as in a
social contract users will voluntarily
relinquish things they value in the
physical world privacy security personal
data in order to gain benefits that come
with being connected to the virtual
world so in other words there is a
trade-off well there's absolutely
trade-offs and and the fact of the
matter is that the technology that our
that our industry is producing naturally
had a gathers information about you does
everyone here know that your phone knows
exactly where you are
yeah do you know why emergency services
anyone here opted out of your mobile
phone because it knows where you are it
has to know where you are that's how the
system works it's the same principle but
it's for the emergency service that
wouldn't be regarded as a loss of
freedom I personally I regard privacy as
an aspect of freedom to be free so
you'll say we trade a bit of for who we
are but it has to be clear that in the
book and I'll say here again I'm very
concerned that we're going to lose our
privacy over time that we have to fight
for it and if we don't fight for it
we'll lose it and the reason has to do
with the logic of security right so here
in Britain not for these horrific
terrorist bombings that you all had you
adopted the CCTV system which the
majority of British citizens are
comfortable with America does not have
that and the CCTV system is relatively
thoroughly regulated as best I can tell
so that's an example of a model of a
trade-off of security and so forth there
are analogous things that you could
imagine online in Google's case for
example and everybody should know that
we retain the search history that you
have when you search on Google for
somewhere between 12 and 18 months that
amount of time was determined by the
European Union and we just said yes it's
an arbitrary number and that's an
example of a trade-off between your
privacy and the ability for the
legitimate police and other public
safety functions to figure out what
people are up to I'm not going to take
the position of whether it should be 12
days 12 months or 12 years but the fact
of the matter is that's how it was
sorted out those are decisions that
Google should not be making
the Henry Kissinger you talked to in the
book and he's somewhat dissident from
some of your points yes one of the
things he says which relates to what
we've just been talking about is that he
could not imagine the Churchill or a de
Gaulle imagined from that emerging from
this connected world
he says unique leadership is a human
thing and it's not going to be produced
by a mass social community that is that
is correct and that is indeed what Henry
Henry told us we went to see dr.
Kissinger precisely because we wanted to
get a perspective of somebody who was at
a geopolitical view that was different
from ours
and roughly summarizing his view is that
leadership turns out to be very rare in
human societies he's a fan of de Gaulle
he uses him as an example these leaders
are very rare we were talking about the
Arab Spring in our observation is it's
much it's very easy to start revolutions
now everybody gets together on Facebook
and Twitter and so forth have a little
crowd get excited have a few you know
have the police overreact have the
government who they're clueless anyway
over-reaction up down the internet boom
out goes the leader you have a new
country not that complicated right
that's really what happened after years
of oppression bad behavior police state
he can lack of economic growth lack of
opportunity for college-educated people
it was time for that system to go who
replaces it well our observation is that
it takes decades to develop leadership
skills to lead humans right decades to
learn how to speak to inspire to
Americans would say to lie to you know
all of the things that we say that - I'm
not speaking for Britain it just takes a
long time to develop those skills and so
a 25 year old who is a truly brilliant
executor of a revolution is probably not
going to be the next president of a
hundred million person comforted our
country for that reason and an indeed
that's what you see with Arab Spring so
now you've got a real mess because
you've got heightened expectations
because everyone's now online everyone
says ok good you know we've had the
party now we want to actually grow we
want to fix these things and then the
really hard part of building a country
which is by the way an independent legal
system respect for the rule of law
curtailing corruption free and fair
elections figure out what the
Constitution says these are
extraordinarily difficult things for any
society to do and on internet time
they're almost impossible to do and you
make the same points in two different
formerly er in the book where you talk
about loss of heroes in fact it's very
hard to imagine given that we're now
recording the lives of every single
human being starting at birth what they
say where they go what they do forever
right by the time they're fifty years
old and there are these sort of national
figures and we know every single
sentence and so forth and so on and
misbehavior especially when they were 15
they were drunk and they should have
been I mean how will society react that
we've never had this problem before but
it's quite it's quite a significant one
I think what forward well how how will
leaders emerge from such a situation is
that constant
well leaders will emerge you know Bill
Clinton said I didn't inhale right
Barack Obama said I did inhale and I
enjoyed it Michael Bloomberg said the
same thing so the fact of the matter is
societal mores may change it may be that
it may be eventually be that people will
say just ignore all the stuff I did
below the age of like 22 or 25 or
something like that I'm much more
concerned about this transition period
here's an example today shortly in
America and I think here as well you're
tolerant of juvenile mistakes so you
have a small run-in with the law that
kind of stuff you can largely get these
things expunged from your record but
there's no way to get things expunged
from the internet in the book we say
that there is no delete button right and
I give you another example in a second
so the fact that there's no delete
button means that there's this
instantaneous record so what happens in
America for example is an employer here
you are your 24 year old you're highly
educated and the employer record says
look a great resume and a great schools
great GPA and all that kind of stuff and
then they spend all their time looking
on your Facebook profile and they say
this is the last person I ever wanted my
company now is that legal absolutely
should it be legal that's a question
that governments are gonna face give you
another example a gentleman in America
decided to publish the plans to build
using 3d printing we should talk about
in the book a plastic gun that's largely
on largely undetectable there's a
relatively crude weapon but it does work
and it will kill people in his
brilliance he uploads this to the
internet and it gets copied all around
the world the US government in their
usual fast acting style wakes a few days
and then discovers that exporting guns
of this category is violates a munitions
law and the order the site to take the
into this information down okay so at
the moment all of the most evil people
in the world right in all these random
wacky countries have plans that will
allow them to using 3d printers make
guns that can be used and smuggle
through airports to kill people now did
this gentleman commit a crime I don't
think so
did he commit a human moral crime you
betcha
yeah we really did because there's no
delete but there was a floor with a gun
that required a nail to be put in it I
go in so it wasn't completely exportable
through well presumably you keep a nail
in here so you know they don't x-ray
your shoes there and by the way nails
are generally available in most
countries has to be a particular nail
but my point my point about the the gun
is that is that there's gonna be another
brilliant idiotic stupid guilty person
who will next year upload a better
design thinking that he's making the
world better by publishing ways of
killing people how is this a good thing
because people don't understand that
this information was published cannot be
retracted the book is a very broad look
as if you are sort of talking about the
governance of the world in the future
and you're pretty skeptical about
politicians as are we all that you have
and this troubles me slightly because
I'm not quite sure what you're saying
this virtual world or the Google world
of the world is relative to current
centers of power I know he's Larry Page
your chief executive said suggested I
couldn't tell me if it's not true but I
read it sounds of extrordinary
Internet company should not be subject
to laws older than 50 years he also
talked about settings are setting a
company up on an island away from the
meddling god I've never heard those
quotes so we will use our favorite
search engine check if somebody in the
audience could check that what was the
exact quote let's actually check it
Larry Page said Internet companies
should not be subject to laws older than
50 years I believe it was illegal and
somebody check if that's actually true
this is the benefit of okay yeah we have
one we have one gentleman here at the
front show me the search result and you
can use Bing it's okay
you can use being asked questions about
Google well in any case I won't comment
on on the alleged quote the let's start
by the the statement that the world's
gonna get connected and that people are
going to be empowered and I'm quite sure
of this the number Android phones nine
hundred million activations which means
there's more than a billion smartphones
there's roughly two billion users of the
internet today there's roughly seven
billion people on the planet so that
says we've got five billion to go by our
current estimate somewhere between the
next five and ten years the vast
majority they're running five billion
people will join the internet almost
exclusively for their smartphones so you
go through what then happens
well obviously governments have a lot to
say about citizens behavior and some
governments will think this is fine
certainly Britain will promote this
America will grow at this Europe is
promoting broad digital literacy
broadband all the sorts of things
what about countries that don't really
are not really soaked together are
they're not running quite the right way
they're gonna be afraid of this and we
worry and we talk about this in the book
that China could for example develop an
export business of its censorship China
today has what is known as great Chinese
firewall which censors the results that
go through into into China and back out
and they'll shut down the connection if
it has information for example about
Falun Gong etc the list of things they
censor is illegal to publish but I can
tell you there's religious religious
movements and things which are
embarrassing to the senior leaders that
technology could easily be exported in
sort of a minerals for censorship trade
so we worry that when that occurs it
should if it occurs the Internet becomes
balkanized and by balkanized I mean the
fact that people have a different
experience and I'm quite concerned that
humans do pretty well when they don't
know what they're missing in terms of
information in China the censorship
system seems to work in the sense that
the average Chinese person is not aware
of what they're omitting and they seem
to be able to do just fine Jared and I
and my daughter went to North Korea and
I figured you know you'd go to Korea
you'd see all these people sort of you
know starving and with pitchforks
against the windows and so forth and so
on I mean you
have this expectation of human disaster
because they don't have access to
information you know they're being
treated mistreated in all the ways but
in fact you know mom's taking the kids
to school gentlemen going to work and so
forth it looked like a reasonably
orderly society you of course don't see
what's missing
so I worried that this trend of
government's trying to sort of shape the
Internet in their own image another
example you know you come up lights of
examples imagine a rock which was where
Jared and I both were and my daughter
Iraq decides to solve a cue the Kurd
problem by simply segregated the Kurdish
internet to its own thing the best
example are the Iranians where we
decided not to visit because it was too
dangerous and the Iranians announced two
weeks ago that they did not like Google
Earth so they're going to have Iranian
earth an Iranian man
an Iranian earth is an excellent product
and it omits Israel I mean what do you
say to this this is the stupidest thing
ever just staying on the subject of
global politics I mean a global conflict
a couple of things that nice if you
develop 20 as you say robots and drones
will increase conflict around the world
but will decrease the likelihood of war
another is that it will there'll be
fewer genocides but more more harassment
and more discrimination fill that out
let's go through the genocide example
this relatively easy it's easy to
understand we went to Rwanda Jared had
been a seminal book on the 1994
conflicts so I learned all about Rwanda
both from him and from the people on the
ground and also their president his
victorious leader in the fight roughly
750 people 750 thousand people were
killed in a four month period by
machetes in the most brutal way possible
the only way that can happen is with
planning you know it doesn't happen
randomly don't just say oh let's wake up
and kill our neighbors of the other
tribe had I do the thought experiment
it's imagine if everyone in Rwanda
mobile phones and they large leader
today and obviously they didn't twenty
years ago we would have known somebody
would have leaked the plans somebody who
said hey these guys over here are
planning to kill all their neighbors
something would have happened to either
stop or lessen the sort of terrible
things that would happen during this
conflict with respect to the notion of
robotic war it looks to us that there's
gonna be a series of gradations of war
so for example with China it looks to us
like China and the United States are
going to have a pretty serious code war
as we call it so it's sort of a thing of
it as a cyberspace war tryna attack
Google for example it is alleged I don't
personally know that America is doing
things to China as well and on and on
and on it's gonna go on on and on and on
whereas whereas in the physical world
China and the United States have
relatively good relations given the
differences in their systems lots of
money going back and forth lots of
travel relatively open borders etc and
sorry you stopped before I was expecting
you hmm so the the the this point about
you make about well first of all about
the nature of technology itself which
comes up in the book you're on page 66
you say the central truth of technology
industry is that technology is neutral
that people are not and then on page 21
hundred and twelve we say technology
companies export their values along with
their products now these are
contradictory statements unless I'm
misunderstanding
well again perhaps perhaps as the author
I did not quite get the paragraph right
let's start with a statement that
technology can be used for good or evil
and so in my industry people tend to say
the technology is neutral I would say
the technology is neutral comma and has
an empowerment bias and an empowerment
bias by the way I do not mean that as an
only positive bias it can also be a
negative bias in other words it empowers
citizens in particular and I think over
the next five or ten years we will be
reacting to the empowerment of citizens
and also people who weep
receive as idiots right oh my god of
course this will be great for newspapers
because there's always a crazy person
doing something stupid that they can
cover and say oh my god this occurred
this occurred this occurred and the rate
at which such examples will increase
because numerically the number of crazy
people will will be added when we
originally built the internet it didn't
occur to us that there be any crazy
people on it and indeed I might the
first network that I built when I was a
graduate student only had passwords in
clear-text it didn't occur to us that
thing would even steal passwords
that's how naive we were now we're not
that naive anymore but it gives you a
sense of the bias the bias that we had
with respect to the second quote we
argue and this is a somewhat
self-serving argument about Google that
one of the best ways to change a society
is to have well-run global
multinationals whose values you believe
in that you support in those countries
so Google for example will not
discriminate against women in the
workforce we're roughly meritocratic and
I think that's pretty well established
it's illegal for Google as a US company
to engage in corruption or something
called the Foreign Corrupt Practices Act
so we and there's a lot of evidence when
we want around and I'm not trying this
to Google Suarez too many other many
other global companies including many
British companies they're one of the
greatest ways to change as a society is
to infiltrate from within with a new set
of values because these people in these
countries are they're humans just like
us they're just trapped in the wrong
system so if you go back to North Korea
when we went to North Korea how gonna
deal with the problem then or three
other sort of the Hermit Revolution
nobody wants to talk to them they don't
talk to anybody they hate the Chinese
and they're dependent upon the Chinese
the embargoes don't work because they're
full of Chinese goods that and goods
from other countries that have been
smuggled through China we were taken to
a shopping center that was full of
American products which by the way had
brand-new equipment women staffing it
and of course no customers because there
was no money in the country it's a
purely purely fake store how do you do
how do you change the society you change
it from within and you change it by
infiltrating the country with new ideas
what's the best way to get those new
ideas on to the mobile device
they have mobile devices all the
internet all the country has to do was
turn on the internet they've chosen not
to right after we left they turned on 3G
roaming three weeks later they turned it
off again what's to say I'm going to
disagree with you on both those points
um the the technology is neutral it
seems to me to be misunderstanding who
are technology you can claim that
science is neutral it's a difficult
claim and scientists struggle to
maintain it and they very seldom succeed
and and it's it's charged for
objectivity but as soon as they turn
away from the bench and as soon as they
are in the world things happen they've
got involved in things now technology is
the application of science mathematics
and so on so it can't be neutral it's a
decision you take to predict would use
this particular thing I mean when you
design an interface it ceases to be
neutral it's a design to do something I
think we're talk about neutrality in
terms of you see I understand the
distinction you're making the one of the
things that's always a surprise to
technical people is that human beings
don't don't do what they thought that
they were going to do with their product
so that's where we come with this
technology is neutral with empowerment
in violence we offer these products up
we want people to use them well but evil
people will use them too there's example
after example a fun example it has to do
with Bluetooth the people who design
Bluetooth which is the network that goes
from your headset to your phone it's a
very simple network very low bandwidth
did not think that it would become the
peer-to-peer network to smuggle out the
images of the Green Revolution out of
Iran but the way we found out the
horrific things were happening in it in
2009 was that people used Bluetooth
networks to smuggle to smuggle the
information to a border point and then
they got it out from there so people are
remarkably clever in these countries
yeah and but but this brings up to the
the other point which is that you can't
be making neutral technologies you must
be making technologies to sell
advertising there are well you just have
the same fiduciary responsibility well I
can answer a Google question are very
simple Google has
a group of people who make ads and
they're clearly selling ass google has a
set of products which are ad supported
which are clearly commingled if you will
guilty in the sense of the tone of your
question and then there's a set of
groups that have nothing to do with ads
let me give you an ad for a product
which is nothing to do with ads which is
Chrome
if you care about security you should be
using Chrome this is the strongest
browser if you care about speed you
should be using Chrome if you care about
price
you should be Croat using Chrome because
it's free and by the way it does not
itself come with any ads that's an
example you do a lot of things flying
company today gathers up solar power
together yes but you do a lot of you
diversify a lot the things that it's
it's easier if I simply say that Google
does by virtue of the founding and the
structure of governance of the company
the company famously says we do things
which we think matter that will make the
world a better place so we assert the
right to spend lots of money on products
which don't carry ads because we think
that people will like them now if we
spend lots of money for a product that
doesn't collect ads that nobody likes
then that's a terrible error right but
you're making these products so that you
know this isn't feeding into the bottom
line as such he's probably I can assure
you we don't Google News for essentially
forever and ever had any never have any
ads whereas Google Shopping did interact
with Google Shopping we went from a free
service to an advertiser
essentially an advertising paid service
we make this is a kind of metaphysical
position for Google that it has these
values that will cause you to be
corporations have a personality and a
culture and when you found a company you
found it typically with the founders
attitudes right and in tech the
companies sort of the personality of the
company is highly highly correlated with
the founders or the early leaders and
the reason by the way has to do with
selection bias right the the sort of top
technical person top salesperson has a
choice of which company's so they see
the ones that are romantic and the ones
which are technical and the ones which
are aggressive
the ones which are sort of kumbaya you
know and they fit themselves into that
sort of personality the google
personality is very precise and
well-documented which is that we want
people who believe that there's a
greater mission to what they do and that
we focus on solving the problems of end
users it's not perfect we make mistakes
and they're the press of course it
covered those exhaustively but the fact
of the matter is that's how we mission
and there I can tell you that in the
decade I was a CEO and now for two years
as a chairman every day there's an
example where we make a trade-off in
favor of a user and against revenue I'll
give you an example of China right as
far as I know we're the only company to
have given up the revenue opportunity
that was represented by search in China
because we were unwilling to be censored
by China China is a very big place as a
lot of Chinese people there's a lot of
advertising revenue that we gave up
because it violated our basic principles
there's a kind of elephant in the room
where you've led into the room there
which is that the taxation sure because
you could perfectly well say that if for
those are your values and you should be
paying the taxes well we are paying the
taxes that we're about to you're going
to enormous lengths to avoid them and
you say that is your fiduciary duty well
Louis since you brought it up let me
let's talk about what about the
international tax regime and I'm
somewhat perplexed by this issue so and
I'm happy to answer more questions you
know on this so the international tax
regime has existed for decades and
American companies have been structured
like this for decades the international
tax regime also applies to British firms
operating in America you know European
firms operating in America and it goes
something is something like this
depending on exactly where you close
business exactly how you operate you pay
taxes in those countries so the software
industry evolved to the structure
involving Ireland which has been again
very very well documented and this is
perfectly legal
now if Google were not to have done that
we would have opened ourselves to
significant criticism and more in
America because we're supposed to
operate that way
and so then how would we account for the
difference is that a donation
again I'm asking as a question I don't
know so we adopted that model
I don't think companies should make
decisions about taxes I think the taxes
decisions should be made by governments
and so if the government here changes
the tax rules we will follow and
furthermore I'll tell you very clearly
that we love Britain we're investing
heavily we have 3,000 employees we're
adding another couple thousand building
a huge Centre in Kings Cross we don't
need lots of things to people we're
doing all sorts of things too because we
actually look we actually like like
Britain a great deal the fact of the
matter is we would do that regardless of
the tax rates but so yeah I mean sorry
just one last question on the tax white
person you Google probably pays a much
lower proportion list of taxes than
anybody in this room nah not globally I
don't know okay UK but again I'm
answering your question in the context
of the international tax regime yeah so
you're right in other words I completely
did the record I completely agree with
you this is a government issue and by
the way I should say that no rational
computer scientist would ever have
designed the International tax regime
this way right
it will defeat your logic trust me
I've never met a rational computer
scientist well computer scientists like
structure and order and that simple
spreadsheets and so forth this is not
what it is this is how it works yeah but
I mean you've said and we want to
discussion about tax you what do you
think it should be a debate what how
much more tax do you think Google should
be paying if you weren't CEO to the taxi
to say how much tax to pay it's up to
the government to say we're not chairman
it executive chairman and Google in this
moment I I would have to sort of look at
it I mean I honestly don't know and I'm
not gonna make something up one of the
problems in Europe is that you have
widely different tax schemes of among
the European Union members and they make
money up in other way so you have a low
corporate tax rate in one area and by
the way we haven't even gotten into all
the Europe all the u.s. issues around
European tax rates and the fact that
they're not harmonized with respect to
the US rates which is another sort of
morass of tax issues which with people
here won't care very much
people in America would so my position
is figure out what taxes you want to
charge us we will pay them not that
complicated my place taxes should not be
voluntary that's why they're called
taxes by the way do you have an identity
manager do I personally have one no no
well in the book we talk about the
problem of identity you said you talked
earlier about digital identities how
many digital identities do you all have
if we count the number of email
addresses login names that differ and
different services you provide probably
more than one would that be fair right
maybe five this gentleman says more how
many ten twenty twenty you have twenty
the Sirius OS as a volunteer already you
must you must be you must be an early
adopter of important new technologies so
so and because of that we're not gonna
go to a single digital identity for many
reasons partly because I don't think you
want the government to have only one way
to interact with you certainly America
that beats you probably here as well but
also they do different things so go back
to your question about digital
identities and you'll have multiple
think about the country of Iran you have
70 million people they're busy trying to
sort of prevent people from having real
internet freedom so the solution in Iran
is that you each person has a digital
identities so that from the government's
perspective it looks like this five
hundred million digital citizens even
though there's only 70 million and
people use this to evade the
restrictions by the government and so
forth and so on
so you can't quite tell right how many
people really represent this movement to
it so it is good by the way to give the
Iranian government a hard problem here
because they need to figure out how
they're gonna open up their government
and open
access and open up things and similar
things will forever okay I'm going to
open it up to audience now other
microphones yeah there are microphones
please wait for the microphone and I'll
point out - oh it's not with the guy
next to you hi Eric
thanks for coming I wish good many more
successes the future this question is
about when you said it's something wrong
when things are good the society is
created in the image of the comments of
the nation-states how do you think that
is worse than trying to create the whole
world in the image of the corporate
companies the only difference is the
nation-states operate within the
constraints of nationalism and the
companies operate still put in a set of
other parameters like corporate
nationalism in light of that question
can you also answer how far are you
willing to go in terms of defending
righteousness like the example you gave
us you stopped the services in China
when you believe that your principles
are not applicable will you will you do
it when every other continent is going
to do the same between being sustainably
profitable and righteousness what's
going to be a choice thank you well I
would argue that in China we proved what
you call the righteousness which for us
was an application of our principles if
we were faced with the same choices
today we would do the same thing in
another country if that's I hope that's
a clear answer it's probably a mistake
to speculate on other kinds of moral
questions that governments can come up
with but you could speculate that
there's a lot of different scenarios
that governments could come up with
which we would find would be so counter
to our values as a corporation with
respect to this question of nation state
versus country nationalism and corporate
nationalism I think it's important to
remember that as a company we are
subject to many many laws in many
different countries that differ and so
we have large sets of groups who try to
remind us that this is legal in this
country and illegal in this
and they're particularly sensitive in
the areas of privacy in hate speech so
in America hate speech is obviously
despicable what is legal there are many
countries where certain forms of hate
speech are not legal in some countries
it's illegal to criticize the founder or
the King
so Thailand for example there's a series
of laws which are brutally enforced in
Thailand where you're not allowed to
speak badly of the royal family or the
King there's no rules in Turkey about
the Fant and the founders name is
Ataturk and so we work with that as best
we can we view that as sort of a
tolerable problem all right
sort of work through it but ultimately
the way the government solved that
problem is they shut down Google they
arrest our employees in Brazil of ahead
of our Brazilian operations spent an
awful lot of time in both civil and
criminal cases over activities for which
he had no responsibility and we try to
sort those things out yes sir
Eric I've been the other ohmy Toro me
jr. for seven years at Google so I had
the pleasure to hear you speak and
multiple times and I know that as a
technologist you have a lot of
interesting opinions also about a topic
that's really important to me and I
think to a lot of us and that's an
environmental issue all this technology
in the future will and won't come really
to fruition if we don't solve that
problem and I wanted to hear some of
your thoughts about the top so you are
you referring I'm air about energy a
couple a couple of comments the first is
that you see the cost of having open and
free speech which i think was invented
in britain last time I checked when you
look at the people who are fighting
against the data or on climate change in
America because there's this tradition
of having two choices you have 99.99% of
all the people who've looked at this
data including myself on one side and
you have crackpot on the other and the
two are in the same TV show welcome to
America so let's posit that the co2
levels are rising that it's a very
serious problem that there needs to be
coordinated global action and that we
need to come up with some new solution
so the first thing is what is Google
doing here we've made a series of
commitments about being carbon neutral
we're building new state-of-the-art data
centers there's a lot of evidence that
that IT electricity use is rising which
you can use renewables for that and so
forth and so on we've also invested near
a billion dollars in renewable energy
products products and services and
investments which should be good
financially as well as good for the
environment so I'm here to tell you that
it should be possible for each and every
one of you to behave as a rational
business person a sophisticated consumer
to make money and make some progress on
this and again that's counter to what a
lot of people think but I think it's
largely true I worry that we're on a bad
path here and the reason is that we
can't answer the court having now
wandered around two-30 countries and
talk to people they all want what we
want what we have excuse me and to
deliver what they have the total energy
loading that they need is significantly
higher than they have today and I don't
see a good global solution where we tell
them they can't have cars it just
doesn't strike me as likely to work so
we need to come up with some new
solutions in the same sense that
fracking which is essentially a
technological invention where though the
pipes can now move sort of arbitrarily
through the ground to find the gas and
the oil wherever it might be we need
some new ones around around much more
fuel-efficient engines much more
fuel-efficient cars there's evidence
with both wind and solar that wind and
solar are getting to the cost near the
cost of coal at least for new bills and
that's very very encouraging as a
gentleman up there hi thanks coming and
speaking to us today I'd like to draw on
a point that you made earlier and gave
us an example of how do you define what
a country is what country is run well
you said it's very easy for you to say
that China doesn't line up with your
values and Britain does for instance
with free speech but what happens when
it gets great
well we struggle through them every day
and I used the examples I'll give you
three examples Pakistan Turkey and
Thailand in each of those cases they
have shut down YouTube for many many
months in Thailand for example there was
a video that was offensive to the king
and under their law should be taken down
it was taken down immediately
they kept YouTube blocked for
approximately nine months was that
because out of sheer moral outrage in
favor of the terrible destruction done
to the image of their king by the 30
minutes that that video was on or was
that because they didn't want all the
criticism of the military hunter that
was in charge of the time it was present
on YouTube you decide I don't know but
I'm suspicious right that they had
another motive since they've since now
opened up YouTube would have a good
operation there and I think we work
through that with Turkey we go back and
forth spend a fair amount of time in
Istanbul trying to understand this and
it turns out it's illegal for you as a
citizen and Turkey to get an unfiltered
internet connection in your home or your
business what's the definition of the
filter well it turns out it's not
written down in law I met with the
president we went through this not even
the staff could tell you what the rule
of the filtering was it turns out it's a
family filter what's the definition of
what's appropriate to the filter not
only is there censorship in their law
but you're not allowed to know what the
censorship is so that's an example
that's an example where it's a little
too close to the Chinese model in my
opinion we work very hard and yelled at
them and so forth that law is in place
but it hasn't been implemented yet so
again that's the reality of how this
plays out how do you find us the Britain
when this government came in actually
did a set of things which made internet
transparency and openness even more
fundamental so I would congratulate you
all to having gotten to the right answer
after all you invented it they're big
speaking of your relationship who in
this government a government minister
really recently complained that Eric
Schmidt could get in easier to see
Cameron than he could are you worried
about the closeness
Wow no I was the supporter of Cameron
and George Osborne because I knew them
personally and my friends in the US were
extraordinarily shocked that I supported
conservatives because in my world nobody
does that
right but I pointed out that the British
conservatives were actually socially
liberal believed in climate change
thought women should be treated equally
knew these shocking things in America
there's a lady there that was next time
so there's a lot of hands if you just
put them up to it when the question is
finished up there your conversation
about filters is quite relevant at the
moment there's a bit of fuss here about
pornography and children's access and
there's beauty sleep in a report setting
out what view of the impact of this is
on children others debate whether it
should be a you know you should have to
opt in or opt out what's your position
on that the the problem of pornography
is a real one and I think this report I
have not read it but it's been described
to me sort of lays out some of the
negative effects of it and the fact of
the matter is there is adult pornography
on the internet because there are
countries that allow it relatively
freely and then it crosses the borders
this is this no delete button example
that we were describing earlier the
problem that I have is I don't know how
to build a filth filtering engine that
would block this pornography you can't
there's no technical algorithms that we
can use to detect it people have tried
by the way pretty hard so you end up in
a situation where you're deleting DNS
entries those are the names of URLs and
the moment you start doing that you're
putting in a filtering regime that could
be extended to things which are not what
we would in this audience agree is adult
pornography in the arab world for
example adult pornography is highly
illegal but the interpretation in their
laws of filtering or
four countries by the way they do
filtering and one for my another
includes an awful lot of quote
pornography which we would agree these
political speech criticism of the king
criticism of the ruling party so I worry
with any conversation about filtering
that it's a slippery slope I understand
what people proposed it but since we
can't detect the evilness of it if you
will I worry it's a series of steps
I'd much rather deal with these problems
why better education my better
understanding of the roles of parents
those of you who are parents let's say
you have a two-year-old I would sit down
with your two-year-old tonight or
tomorrow morning when he or she wakes up
and I'd say I am going to know your
password until you're 18 and when
they're three you're gonna have their
birth that you're gonna say the same
thing when they're four you're gonna say
I want to know your password in the
eighteen so by the time they're about
fifteen and they say why do I have to
give you your passport from your entire
life the policy this family has been I
know your password that's how I so I
would encourage a strong parental role
pornography is just one example of
harmful information that could be seen
by children they could actually and if I
if I had children of that age today I'd
be all over this
I think torn up fairly internet was
actually created by a Supreme Court
decision because in the late eighties a
better about swear they classified
hardcore pornography is free speech in
America well the Internet is a global
phenomena in date but and as far as I
can tell pornography has been in this
part of the world - yeah but but the
American companies would not be able to
do it if that Supreme Court decision had
gone the other way and America is
obviously the dominant force in the
internet this is too much of a leak
trust me
Americans go to the continent and the
the amount of adult pornography and the
harshness of it and so forth and it's
open to shocks even us liberal Americans
so I would I would just disagree with
their framing I think that the in
America the there's a series of very
famous cases which involved you know I
can't define pornography but I know it
when I see it which was the famous just
Justice Stewart quote and there were a
series of Prosecco
finn's in more conservative states which
were over overturned for that reason it
would be very if you had such a rule
today you'd still have to have a
definition of it and since there is not
agreed-upon definition because countries
differ I don't know how you'd solve this
problem okay gentlemen there hey thank
you um in what way do you think the
institutional monopoly on education will
change in response to these brands named
universities putting their degree
courses and lectures online like MIT
excellent so I know a little bit about
the British system because I was
involved in arguing that the British
system was not producing enough computer
scientists I wanted to take a minute and
say that after a lot of discussion the
British educational system has now made
computer science hard sciences one of
the sort of core sets of classes that
university students have to do there's
an insufficient number of computer
scientists and sort of the science type
people in Britain given the percentage
of people there's simply too many smart
British people that need to be in this
that we're not getting properly educated
and I think that's large have been fixed
so that's a serious win for Britain and
I'm very happy to have watched that in
the last couple of years I can take you
through the details if you're interested
in the the question to me in America
which I'm more familiar with in
education is what's it going to take to
really change the structure of American
education because the organization's are
remarkably indifferent and change
resistant to data and so here you have
professors and teachers who teach
statistics and AV tests but they don't
actually evaluate any choices they make
they just decide all right they don't
look at outcomes they don't measure them
in any rational way and parents
desperately want better educational
systems for their students so there's a
series of now online worlds where you
can really test whether the kids are
getting better education I'm on the
board of something called Khan Academy
which is targeted at 10:00 to roughly 17
year olds it's hugely successful if you
haven't looked at it here it's very
successful in Britain
keh and Academy and it's essentially
videos that the students watch at home
and the classroom the theory with again
modern and sophisticated teachers is
they do group problem solving and
there's evidence that that produces
better outcomes than the traditional way
and with teaching is done so if it's if
it works great
EDX is an MIT group there are a number
of other for-profit ones one it's called
Coursera these are in the process of
doing the same things for universities
right that they're now our global
resources which you can compare and to
me this is a real positive effect let's
get a little competition of the
educational system let's just get the
teachers to prove that they're as good
as they think they are teachers are
incredibly important all right but let's
let's have some measurements about
outcomes let's get people the best tools
let's give them career opportunities
let's give them the tools that fits get
the classrooms wired all of that
together will ultimately produce a great
outcome my observation about the
educational systems is they're largely
been run for the benefit of the parents
and the teachers in other words for the
adults and not the kids an education is
supposed to be about the kids so let's
measure the kids outcome figure out how
we can make it better and iterate until
we get world-class outcomes and and in
case you you you think that I'm just
sort of making this stuff up what's the
competitive issue globally for Britain
than for America it's the Asian
educational model it's not Asia it's the
Asian educational model you may not like
these countries and they certainly are
not places that I would want to live
given my sense of civil liberties and
rights and I suspect British people
would feel the same way but the fact of
the matter is they produce a higher
percentage of extraordinary talented
engineers mathematicians and scientists
and that ultimately means technological
innovation moves to there and ultimately
perhaps global companies that could
could provide even more competition
cause more job issues and so forth and
so on in our part of the world it's a
very serious issue
the next man up that
I was just wondering if you ever worry
about that the humanizing nature of some
personal technologies I mean you just
talk about education person just
wondering yeah but you ever concerned um
I would argue that most the technology
is more humanizing rather than less so
maybe you could give an example of what
you mean good question um back at me I
mean in terms of sight communication I
mean you talk about digital
personalities and people perhaps
becoming slightly different individuals
online or oil is creating you know
different personalities for themselves
in life is that slightly I'll let you
then then come to your own conclusion on
that I would argue that for decades
people have assumed that you would end
up having people sitting at home it was
called Bowling Alone was the phrase the
people would sit at home they'd be
lonely they'd have their television the
television would be attached to their
head in some way they'd have no friends
and they'd be miserable it looks like
that's completely wrong it's a hundred
percent wrong there's evidence that
because of the new technologies which
include social networks texting and so
forth people have more friends than they
did before they can span more than real
friends who move well the Dunbar number
is 150 people so from your perspective
you should have at least 150 friends
that's how according to the scientists
that's roughly the correct number so the
fact of the matter is I would say that
certainly my reach as a human being is
far far greater because I can email and
text people and if you if you're
confused about this go and watch a movie
from 30 years ago before cell phones in
before texting so I watched la story and
that happened at two movies that I
happen to remember from when I was
younger so the basic thesis in the
Manhattan movie is as a woman that has a
lot of people trying to get to her well
she has the telephone at home and she
has to answer it because there's no
caller ID and she can't quite figure out
oh no no no I can't talk to you now boom
right and so forth and so on you forget
all right that with these tools and
techniques you can
decide how to spend your time and who
with and so forth there's example after
example pick some set of British
comedies go back 30 years you'll see how
much your life has changed lady that
thank you and just to return to the tax
issue you say that it's up to
governments to make sure that companies
pay tax and I I'm sure that's fine for a
company that doesn't claim any great
virtues but Google's made a lot over the
years about it its virtues its values as
a corporate citizen I think most people
think that one of the manifestations of
being a responsible individual or
corporate citizen is to pay your way and
you're wack as far as tax it's concerned
and I think therefore that a lot of
people are left with the impression that
Google is somewhat hypocritical would
you care to comment I'm not happy to as
I mentioned the first days this why
would companies not want to have high
taxes just in general because they can
then use the remaining money to invest
and so Google invests an enormous amount
of money in future and speculative
projects which if the tax rate were for
example 100 percent which you're not
proposing and I'm not proposing and I
assume the government wouldn't do would
not occur so from a corporate
perspective company we understand we
have to pay taxes we have to follow them
my conundrum is that if we pay more than
the minimum right how do I classify that
right so if you if you think we're
behaving illegally which is false then
you should investigate us and and so
forth and indeed I'm sure that will
occur but the fact of the matter is what
we're doing is legal so anything beyond
that that's taxes to some degree either
we have to fear how to classify it and
at least in theory for a corporation it
could serve as an investment drag so
there's no question that the government
needs more money we're not arguing that
and I think that's true in all of these
countries so I don't know how to solve
that problem right now I think the
government should decide what the tax
rate for a company should be and I think
we should follow it well but the latest
more that's my question and I think as I
said I agree with you
government should set taxes and so on
but is there a sense in which this you
Google's rhetoric since the beginning of
being another a new kind of company a
different kind of company with different
values is running into a brick wall here
because people are angry about taxes
they're getting upset about everything
doesn't make Google look quite as cool
as it once did well that all I can do is
show up and try to answer the question
right the best I can and I'm not
defending as I said I said with some
ridicule I described the current system
and that's about all I know how to do I
could imagine lots of things that Google
could do to make the world a better
place that we've chosen not to paying
more than the taxes that we're required
is certainly one but there are certainly
many other things that we could do it
would also be highly beneficial to the
world that we've chosen not to because
we couldn't think of it or we couldn't
get around to it or those sorts of
things okay attention than that thank
you I once I asked a question about Ray
Kurzweil and your recent hiring of him
as a as a director of engineering we had
him over here as part of the MIT
Enterprise for him a couple years ago
he's a fantastic futurist his goal is to
build a human mind according to his last
book so I'd love your comments on that
and just a tiny follow-up question is
there anything to do with his hiring
associated with the Google book scanning
project as well so the good news is that
you'd you ask the perfect question and I
cannot answer that question the reason
is that we don't discuss our future
unannounced products but a reasonable
presumption on your part as an
intelligent number of the this sort of
community is that we hired ray to work
hard on the things he talks about
thank take it one more at that and the
second part of the question is that
anything to do with the book scanning
project can't answer that question
either but I will tell you watch this
space I would believe we're in the
signatures but that's a more complicated
question okay good I will take a whole
hour to discuss what I would tell you is
that Rey represents a set of brilliant
people who believe that using the
computational power that companies like
Google have that we can actually get to
a new level of intelligence and
understanding he has built a team to
look at this this is something that
we're very very interested in it's very
early to speculate on exactly how you
would see it but raised record as an
inventor says that he will change the
world again I strongly recommend you
read the review of Kostas book in The
New York Review of Books by calling
McGinn you might change your mind
somebody please read it next one all
right I was wondering if you could talk
a little bit about Google's current
involvement in education I think I've
largely spoken about about what's going
on in education Google itself is not
heavily involved in the educational
initiatives that I described that's an
example by the way of things which we
could spend a lot more time on but we've
made which would make the world a better
place which we have not we built a plant
a platform which is called course
builder which became the underlying
platform for many of the experiments
that are now becoming popular and indeed
we were the sponsors of the first MOOC
course a MOOC course is a course that's
largely taught online with an AI course
done by Google employees at Stanford
which had a hundred and fifty thousand
students in it that's extraordinary we
sort of proved the point so we were
there at the beginning I don't know how
much more will do versus let the that
let the competitive markets work
themselves out there's a lady over in
the corner that's here sorry this come
on it's sorry commander sorry
but no he's he's virtually in silhouette
like yes thank you for that so my
question was with to do with the
comments on the impact of the internet
on war and genocide so you can see the
way that the internet kind of helps
people from all over the world
especially where it's free connect but
in these countries where they have
strict filters is there not a risk that
you get dangerous propaganda almost by
omission and you can can create
propaganda that makes people want to go
to war and want to hurt their fellow
people I agree with that and let's use
the example in Rwanda of this hate radio
station that was used to actually signal
many of the massacres and so forth and
had that radio station been destroyed by
the Tutsis and they no one quite knows
why they couldn't find it or they didn't
destroy it
it would have saved significant lives my
answer in general is the answer not to
reduce the amount of information but to
increase the number of information
sources so in most of these cases if you
have somebody who's all into hate speech
let's get five other people who are into
non hate speech and let's get people
educated enough to understand that they
should look at multiple choices that
they should think before they act
humans can be mobilized they can be
radicalized they can be taught that
there's only one way to do things that
person is a pretty unsafe person people
are naturally however curious and so if
we can educate them it'll be different
if countries shut down the way you're
describing think about Syria today right
was the internet has now been shut down
there will be people who will build
various mechanisms to get information
out of their Google and Twitter built a
product called speak to tweet where you
can call a phone number and when you
call this phone number Google's voice
will then take your tweet and ship it
out on here to
feed it's the only way to get to at
least tell people what you're doing tell
people you're alive report what's going
on that's had a huge impact so even
those situations information is very
powerful I think he's a man that won't
hire I had a kind of two pronged
question about what you're saying
earlier about CCTV which was quite
interesting because Google has just
unveiled Google glass which i think is
quite interesting and a question really
a bit but what happens to the opt-out
when it starts invading people's space
so when someone else is wearing a pair
of glasses and can be taking pictures of
you at all times without you really
being aware of it how did they what does
that do to the opt-out when when
technology starts to infiltrate the
physical spaces we're starting to see
now and we'll start to see up the next
ten years or so so a little bit of
background is that Google five years ago
would have just sort of announced Google
glass Google is different now and so
with Google glass if you haven't used it
it's an extraordinary product it's a
little screen it's this up here you
could talk to it you say okay glass and
it talks back to you in your ear you do
queries and so forth various people have
figured out a way to get the camera
that's in that to take pictures and also
to show you what's going on there are
many many many interesting applications
that people are proposing with this your
fear is right in that without knowing it
you could end up with people recording
without your knowledge and so Google has
spent quite a bit of time trying to
figure out how to release that those
components without violating your
privacy and there are extreme examples
for example of face recognition where
we've said publicly and all the peat
again we're not going to do that without
appropriate privacy safeguards in place
it's too early to say exactly how we're
gonna do that but that work is underway
now and I would encourage people rather
than assuming something is terrible what
sort of a normal human thing these are
real real innovations let's let let's
try them let's see how they work let's
see what problems they solve and some
new problems that they may create and
work with them at the moment there are
only 2000 or so in the world and so
we have some time or more at that hello
I wonder if you could say where the saw
a difference between knowledge and
information particularly in the field of
education I'm thinking I hope I've
attributed this quote to you correctly
but a while ago did you not call for
geeks with Greeks that I thought was a
wonderful quote and but but then you
know when you start talking about the
need to measure and outcomes well in
Britain we've had decades of trying to
measure an outcome things in education
and to know great profit and so I
wondered how you and quite often I think
information and knowledge get confused
so I'd be interested in your thoughts on
how you saw the difference and secondly
there's a lot of evidence that critical
thinking is underlies all sort of
knowledge the ability to manipulate
symbols manipulate concepts this is true
in reading it's true in problem-solving
it's true an art you know can you think
critically can you you express what
you're trying to do can you understand
the context in which you're operating
and so forth there are new mechanisms to
teach critical thinking that have
emerged admit that hold great promise
with respect to the measurement question
I simply disagree that you cannot
measure some of these outcomes and I
observe that in society we're measured
off time right we're measured by our
families were measured by businesses
were measured by schools and grades and
so forth so we're better off figuring
out ways to approximate measurement
right to to here to different trombone
players and try to figure out who's
better to serve as incentives I do feel
very strongly that humans will react to
those incentives in a good way when
they're done properly ethically
that is literally my view you had a same
question yes I did the second one was
what what you thought about the lady
could be urban previously mentioned the
worries about pornography that have been
in the news this week
well actually the the report that Tim
it's based on Falls much more into the
field of advocacy research it was
commissioned by the Children's
Commission office with a problem that
was prior you know defined beforehand
and they set out to look for certain
evidence that isn't conclusive anyway
and I thought it sounds like you don't
agree with the report no no I don't and
I really liked your response to what you
would do and it just struck me it seems
a very sensible response and I wouldn't
isn't that something most parents would
would do and should do and why is it
wait so sort of soap questioning and
anxious about what we can do with this
with this new technology that as you say
has the potential to be so great so it
seems to me there's a contradiction
between the fantastic potential and an
increasing fearfulness of ourselves or
our own ability to use it positively
well thank you well first but since I
haven't read the report I don't know its
provenance I can't comment on your your
critical view of it I think we just have
to take that as your view and and hear
other people's views as well it seems to
me that you there's a couple basic
principles in life anything that
increases life and decreases death is
positive anything that increases death
is bad anything that it gets parents
more involved with their children is
positive and whether it's fear or
incentives or so forth we can debate
maybe it's culture maybe it's religion
but at the end of the day society is
better with parental involvement trying
to make sure that that all the trends
are positive with respect to human life
health safety and so forth and so on
and let people come to their full
potential whatever it may be it's a
relatively straightforward position but
I think it's right I do believe that the
technologies that we're talking about
are largely enabling of that goal and
there are issues that we've been
highlighting here that we need to
address related by the
rent sleeve that would be a woman must
be
leaving aside you know some of the
issues that we've been discussing about
terrorists sharing information
pornography etc on a slightly more
mundane level the Internet is littered
with erroneous information things which
are just not true if we step forward
into a world where we're planning to
automate off of information that is then
based on what you can get on the
Internet
I'm not sure you know what the
repercussions would be if you know the
distance between x and y has been
miscalculated online at what stage do we
need to be thinking about quality
control well of course you've just made
a very good search a very good argument
for a search engine our search engines
you know it's the number of sites that
turn up a non factual information on a
regular basis is pretty shocking these
days well the counter-argument I would
make is that the number of sites that
have factual information is also
increasing quite dramatically so if they
wander we didn't know how to filter them
well again we're not into filtering
we're into search that's called Google
and so if we're surfacing factually
false sites to a legitimate query then
we're not doing our job right
that's what ranking is all about and
there are many many ways algorithmically
to do that let me give you an example to
make the point let's go back to the
tobacco companies of 50 years ago in
America and there may have been similar
things here in the UK I don't know they
were aggressively and they were
ultimately convicted of aggressive
misinformation campaigns they were
spending money to mislead people that
smoking was good for their health or at
least neutral which it obviously is not
and the scientists to create so today
imagine this we started over and they
were doing exactly the same thing what
would happen is it'd be all these sites
full of misinformation it'd all be
factually false they would have lots and
lots of sites they would do their very
best to gain Google well two things
would happen first the Google algorithms
would get
better to detect this sort of it's
called Google bombing is the term of
trade and the second is that right
thinking people like the people in this
room would in fact organize to say this
is crazy
right these people are trying to sucker
you or whatever the right British term
is and off you go right and then this
system would equilibrator so given that
there's no book that says exactly what
truth is this is the best that we could
do today with technology I also would
tell you that the use of the Internet is
not a substitute for human judgement I
get emails all the time of did you know
right so for example you gave a quote
which didn't sound like something Larry
would say so I asked to check right and
so we can discuss that but the fact of
the matter is that's the right behavior
let me just read and what's the source
of this Larry Page is tired arrivals
wants to start his own country it said
it was crass I'm pretty sure - when we
got him but I cut them pasted it okay
I'll read it thank you for what happened
last week while I was traveling what one
more one more up there please I use
Google but I don't trust Google and from
what you said earlier it sounds like I'm
pretty unusual and I'm curious as to how
unusual I am in that regard I find it
quite difficult to trust an organization
that's got such a huge amount of power
over the information we bring to
people's attention today and with that
power go it's a huge amount of
responsibility and it's quite a mere
sister who would you trust instead
that's a good question I guess and you
can ask your question that's my question
to you thank you well if you can answer
my question first that would be great
go ahead
go ahead and ask your question and and
just as an aside that adweek Europe
recently law partner was speaking on the
Levinson inquiry into press freedom and
I asked him the same thing about Google
and the power that it has over the
information that that we're now all
consuming and he said well the chats
that Google are very very nice he said I
know them quite well and they seem to be
doing a great job he said but I would
ask them to prove it and so my question
to you is how can you earn my trust so
that I know that your search versus
filtering device that you're using is
not corrupting anyway the information
the on search that I'm receiving from
you well I can so I can actually answer
that question and then I would like you
to ask my answer my question so so
there's a let me tell you how Google
works by policy and so forth we take all
the information that we can find on
these crawls and we organize them using
algorithms that are the best ones we can
and we work very hard to not have biases
and those algorithms then you could
imagine to be lots of different kinds of
biases so the Google search results are
the best that computers programmed by
humans using modern incredibly
sophisticated algorithms can provide
there's certainly no intent to
discriminate or otherwise hurt
information and indeed we are criticized
for the inverse of what you said all the
time which is that we should omit
information so I think you can trust
Google at least as a presenter of
information to have done the best we can
to get all of the information and rank
it and keep it all there even if you
have to go pages after pages after pages
does that answer your trust question or
there are there did I misunderstand your
trust question no I understand how the
algorithm works but what I'm saying is
at the end of the day because of the
nature of your place in the market you
know you are just a sheer number of
people that are relying on you to bring
information to their attention is
absolutely enormous and with that level
with that number of eyeballs looking to
use together to get news you do have a
responsibility so my question was do you
ever do you have a global for example a
global panel of experts that you
take through how you're changing the
algorithm which is changing as people
change the way they create sites and so
forth yeah we do 800 or 900 tests
changes a quarter the changes are
checked very thoroughly using all sorts
of ways involving review panels a B
tests and so forth to see we also they
help me to mention because we're running
out of time just go yeah but we have we
have a person who does not trust Google
and I'm trying to get her to trust I may
fail but I intend to try I'd like to
receive by email the information that
you're talking about about how you do
that and that would be a great first
step okay well again let me say I do
want to try to answer this so when we
make changes and we're again we're not
perfect and we do make mistakes we
actually look at the old versus the new
and we have the user panels and citizens
around the world when we do these we do
them in per country per language and so
forth and so on
and we have a very very sophisticated
review process that looks at precisely
that and we've done that since the
founding of the company I just want to
come to one last question I'm sorry I
don't at one point doesn't the fact of a
suggestion engine rather change that the
suggestion engines are are different
technology let me describe how
suggestions in work people here have
used Amazon I assume Amazon will if you
buy a product will suggest other
products you've seen that the general
term of suggestion is engineer called
associative matching and what happens is
they say that if you bought X and other
people bought ax they also bought Y and
so you might like Y and you can do this
mathematically in x times y times Z you
can do it with many different kinds of
products and so forth and so on
so the various forms of suggest are a
simple form of artificial intelligence
where the computer is trying to be
helpful that's distinct I think from the
trust question because this suggests is
simply trying to get you faster to your
answer whereas the trust question which
I thought was important was about
completeness and ethical and honesty and
arrangement ok sorry we don't have to
have thought the ranking you get
first page or is more directed to you as
a result of that that is essentially the
suggestion engines have nothing to do
with that ranking if you are logged in
as a Google user and you don't opt out
of the personalization which you can do
you will get somewhat more personalized
ranked answers because it'll know for
example which country you're in it'll
know a little bit about your search
history most people are happy with that
if you don't like it you can turn it off
okay if the the personalization aspect
is relatively mild but if you compare to
people using Google you will in fact see
some differences in their outcomes
precisely because of that ok I'm sorry
this really has to be the last question
no-no-no let's hit the mic so everybody
can hear you thanks that in your book
the young there's an impassioned plea
that you give that we must fight for our
privacy or well lose it and my question
is what shape in your mind does that
fight take and who's on which side and
how we know who won that's a very good
question I don't know the answer I
observe that it's very easy to give up
your privacy for other reasons right so
I mentioned here I am in Britain and I
walk down the street my pictures being
taken it's not being misused as for as
far as I can tell and the police use it
honorably I have lost some privacy there
right
it doesn't particularly bother me but it
does bother other British friends that I
have I might be willing in Boston after
the horrific bombing there to opt in for
the same system because of the
horrendous trauma of the bombing that
occurred at the end of the marathon so
my point in that was to get us to debate
it the Hawks
always win from the standpoint of
surveillance and safety and because you
can't calculate the cost of fear and the
asymmetric power of evil evil people it
would be easy to put yourself into a
situation where you ended up in a
surveillance state not Britain hear what
I'm saying I'll give you an example in
the course of our travels and we mention
this in the book Jared Jared and I and
my daughter indeed again I want to a
place called plataform of Mexico now
we also went to see odd-odd Juarez which
for a while was the most dangerous city
in the entire world which is a serious
win in terms of terror so in ceará
whereas for example the police are in
such danger that the police who were
with us wore face masks so that they
could not be identified and then killed
by the corrupt police so it's quite
something to operate with where the
police are are far hooded protecting us
with machine guns and all this kind of
stuff so the reason they they have this
problem of course is the terrible drug
war and all the money going to the US
and all the drug customers in the US
this is a terrible problem and it's
screwed up the police force on the
government's and a lot of there's a
tremendous amount of corruption so the
government in its infinite wisdom has
built an underground bunker literally
below ground
secured in all sorts of ways where when
there's a traffic stop they can using
modern AI technology figure out who this
person is and who's their associates is
in enough time for the traffic stop to
radio to the police person that one he's
in danger in two he should do his very
best to arrest this person really fast
before everybody gets killed
this is a very serious problem exactly
the same technology could be used by a
future Mexican government to survey and
trap innocent civilians otherwise doing
other things it's the same technology so
what I don't know about Mexico is does
it have the history of free speech of
privacy of individual rights that
countries like Britain and the US do or
are they willing to it's the drug
situation of Mexico so bad that they're
willing to give up even those rights and
I worry about that and that's why we
said it and I think that the the reason
it's good to frame it this way is that
these are ultimately societal choices
and societies will decide them in
different way but every country faces
this challenge going forward okay ladies
and gentlemen thank you very much thank
you
you